having that experience like we had with
Justice League the first time around
where you're like this movie is making a
lot of money
and it's still tanky like I don't want
I'm so nervous to see this like make a
billion point five and people go man
Avatar really underperformed yes
I am shamelessly plugged out today
ladies and gentlemen how you guys doing
we are here today to talk about how
avatar The Way of the water I think they
should have had two does there that's
just my personal opinion the Avatar The
Way of the water the might actually
underperform at the box office because
the expectations are through the roof so
I wanted to go over quite a few things
because I think this is like a really
interesting upheaval battle that the
movie might actually have to endure I
didn't think it would be in this
position but hearing some reports that
have been coming out I'm pretty
surprised by what we're hearing so guys
if you can leave a like for John for
John being here please like John Johnny
can I stop now like button so guys go
for it the main thing that's been taken
off is the fact that James Cameron has
been coming out and saying that this
movie needs to make like two billion
dollars to just break even that's not a
preface that's just for the studio to go
this was worth the time money that is
insane to me like wow how much did this
movie cost because the early reporting
for the budget was like 250 million
dollars and I'm like what you need to
make two billion dollars it needs to
become the third or fourth highest
grossing film in order to burn I'm just
like that it's just nutty to me
there's other things I want to go over
like streaming and other things and why
I think it has a chance of doing it for
sure it's just nuts to me but it's also
the most unique position I think any
filmmaker has ever found themselves in
when it comes to the sheer volume of
business they have to gen like as much
as James Cameron is an innovator and a
pro I would be sweating constantly I
mean yeah because they need to turn a
profit especially if you want to make 14
more Avatar sequels you need to make it
you need to make a buck here man he was
out here saying if Avatar 2 doesn't
perform you know that I guess I'll just
have to wrap it all up in part three and
I'm like if this doesn't perform I don't
know if there will be a studio left to
funny three it's just like the dialogue
that he's like giving in these
interviews I'm like you don't sound the
most optimistic sometimes the way you're
talking about how you think Avatar the
way of water might do because right now
we have early projections estimated and
usually you know Studios try to be a
little bit modest um in the beginning so
you know under promise over deliver is
usually a great way sometimes they start
minimizing that The Closer they get to
the release date but yeah the early
projections right now are between 150 to
170 million dollars which is good yeah
it's not like one of the some of these
Marvel movies that have like an early
projection they can be a little bit
higher still if you mind two billion
dollars now there's some good things
here that that can get them to there all
right like I was looking through some
numbers and they don't really have any
competition for a while all right that's
a great thing Avatar makes for a great
holiday experience the first one came
out around the holidays and did well and
had a really great run also it's getting
a release in China which should
definitely help you have a good boost
the trailer for Avatar the way of water
the first trailer had like I think 148.6
million views on it so if every one of
you buys a ticket it'll break even into
that two billion Mark I think it'll be
like oh it'll be above 2 billion if
every one of you buy the tickets Imax or
a 3D ticket especially it should do well
and this is one of those rare films
where you say 3D and people might be
like you know what yeah let's go see
this in 3D I actually might want to do
it which will help boost ticket sales
now there are some uh things that have
changed though in the in the last 10
years one is was the amount of trailer
views that the movie was getting the
interest was that just because oh
Avatar's back but what is the overall
reception to it like yeah this does look
gorgeous but are people dying to see
this in the theaters secondly to make
that money to make a profit you have to
have people who really want to do repeat
viewings of it yeah that's not movies
like Spider-Man no way home almost made
two billion dollars during the pandemic
because the people kept going back to
the theaters to watch that film same
thing with Avengers end game it did
great like the first Avatar movie with
its re-releases combined this close to
making three billion dollars it's like
very very very close with Avatar the way
of water like we're very excited for it
I think it looks just gorgeous it looks
absolutely gorgeous it looks like a
massive technological innovation and
something that levels up significantly
from the first movie but a common thing
not everyone feels this way I'm just
saying this is a common thing that you
hear about that the movie is beautiful
but the story didn't quite land as
strong as a lot of people were kind of
hoping for right now any movie that gets
super popular usually hears some type of
eventually the criticism becomes a
really strong you know topic of
conversation with any movie that gets
really popular yeah it's the way it goes
it's the way it goes I get it but like
with the way of water I am curious to
know like are most people feeling like
wow I really gotta see this or wow this
feels different or does it just feel
like we're revisiting with just like
some water [ __ ] going on in there you
know what I mean whereas like with some
of these franchise movies you see that
they are doing something like Spider-Man
no way home for just one example like oh
they're bringing all these different
characters in here oh cool like with the
way the landscape is we love like
Crossovers and all this [ __ ]
can we get an avatar crossover going can
Predator land on Pandora can we do that
but even with top gun Maverick coming
back you know there's a Nostalgia factor
of Top Gun in the trailers it is such an
amazing job showing us now this is going
to be a different kind of film
experience for sure one that we haven't
quite had before yet so with this movie
is really going to need more than
anything else it's just the best goddamn
Word of Mouth that has ever existed
right absolutely yeah like this movie's
gonna need insane word of mouth because
when Avatar one came out that was the
thing it was the word of mouth I had
never even seen a trailer a me trailer
reaction guy had never even seen the
trailer for it and I went because I just
love James Cameron movies and I was like
yeah I gotta watch everyone keeps won't
shut up about it so I gotta check this
movie out I want because of that and a
lot of people went to watch Avatar
because it was such a unique experience
but you know it's like as great as this
looks that unique Factor has definitely
diminished now that we've gotten used to
the world of Pandora you know yeah and
more and more like really effects driven
films it's like you have the first
avatar coming out at a time where I
think everybody grasped the idea that
like wow this is a huge technical
Innovation so we can cut the story some
slack and some people like the movie's
story but a lot of people gripe that
it's you know FernGully or any number of
other things and I feel like one thing
that worries me as beautiful as these
trailers looking as much as like the
time passage I feel like is uh help
because anybody who's a bit interested
in the movie business probably can sense
that there's been a lot of innovating
going on in this movie there might be
enough time to build that Nostalgia for
2009 but people are also looking at this
trailer and going first trailer the
teaser the final trailer none of these
really give a sense for what the story
is aside from something that looks a lot
like what we did the first time and
that's the big thing that worries me for
this movie because we've sat here and
gone this looks so beautiful the
cultural aspects that made the first
avatar really touching are all there but
what is going to separate and make the
story stand taller and brighter than the
first movie and that's the thing I think
the movie really needs to prove to
everybody yeah it needs to have that it
needs to be so justified in the fact
that people will want to keep going back
because this movie is also really
freaking long it's a long ass movie I
think James Cameron I forget what the
exact quote is but he was like yeah I
told the studio this is a rough business
venture for everyone involved that's a
thick ass runtime man yeah and so the
movie has to justify you know people
wanting to keep going back to
re-experience that and then of course
the other main topic is streaming is way
more prevalent than ever you know
especially during the pandemic time
we've become more selective now of like
me was already a thing but it's more of
a thing now like do I really need to go
to the theaters to watch this yeah and
that has certainly affected the big
spectacle movies and certainly with
movies that don't have maybe as
appealing of a story from the outside
looking in you know people would be
including to wait for streaming and I
feel like Avatar does have ground to
make up in that there is a camp of
people who are probably not that
enthused and are going to automatically
decide to wait this movie has a chance
of having great legs for for many many
weeks to come even though the first one
made close to three billion dollars
again re-releases combined made it like
to 2 billion uh on it's a traditional
release I believe because yeah I became
like the number one highest grossing
movie of all time so I'm rooting for the
film I'm like I'm rooted for the film
but even from this spectator set I'm
like that's a water to try to just go
all right I didn't lose any money and
two having that experience like we had
with Justice League the first time
around where you're like this movie is
making a lot of money
and it's still tanky like I don't I'm so
nervous to see this like make a billion
point five and people go man Avatar
really underperformed yeah you could
feed a whole nation with the gross
it's failing at the box office still do
you guys think it'll regenerate like a
serious profit do you think it'll come
close to matching The Profit that the
first movie ended up making
because yeah that's a tall order right
there man and there's a lot of things
working against it so to think about oh
wow this movie might actually be getting
all those reports that I see about
wakanda forever and Black Adam
just on the biggest possible imaginable
scale I don't want it to though no I
want them to win I don't want them to as
much as the eye of dogged Avatar in the
past I really hope they succeed because
this is exciting I think they can do it
I'll be more than happy if they do guys
leave your thoughts down below be sure
to subscribe leave a like click that
Bell and keep a lookout for when we do
have our Avatar the way of water review
because uh they're gonna need that
they better hope we like it I hope we
like it because we we are influencers
right and we will influence you into not
seeing it if we don't like it
Think Like Us
[Music]